imaginez nous sommes en 1845 et deux
navires bogue quelque part dans
l'arctique à la recherche du fameux
passage du nord-ouest permettant de
relier plus facilement l'europe à l'asie
mais les bateaux ces gars les glaces se
renferme sur leurs coques emprisonnant
dans un enfer blanc pendant plus de deux
ans laissant 29 membres d'équipage
aucun n'en reviendra vivant c'est le
destin tragique de cette expédition
menée par le britannique seul john
franklyn et qui poursuivait une mission
cartographier cette région
inhospitalière
cette exposition nous fait découvrir le
voyage de franklin pourquoi ils partent
et finalement lors la destinée tragique
de tous ses membres d'équipage notre
coeur
les seuls témoins de ce drame ont été
des communautés inuit qui ont rencontré
des survivants de l'expédition franklin
leurs récits oraux raconte la grande
détresse de ces hommes qui ont souffert
de malnutrition fin maladies diverses et
qui ont dû se résoudre à du cannibalisme
pour survivre c'est grâce à ces récifs
inuit et après des années de recherche
qu'en 2014
une équipe de parcs canada découvre
enfin l'épave de l'airbus
l'un des navires de l'expédition
l'exposition présente pour la première
fois au canada plusieurs des pièces
retrouvées sur ce navire comme ça cloche
une partie de son gouvernail où cette
lettre dite note de victory ponte
tu es vraiment la dernière trace c'est
vraiment la preuve qu'il nous dise si
c'est la fin on part on s'envoie tel
endroit ou quittent le navire
mais ce voyage tragique et les missions
qui se sont succédé pour retrouver les
membres de l'expédition franklyn n'ont
pas été vains cette expédition de
franklin qui était avant tout une
expédition scientifique nous a permis de
découvrir un peu la carte géographique
du canada les découvertes archéologiques
sur cette expédition sont loin d'être
terminée en 2016 c'est l'ehpad du
deuxième navire le tireur qui a été
retrouvé et spécialistes sont donc en
train de l'explorer et s'attendent à
découvrir d'autres témoignages qui
aideront à éclaircir le mystère de
l'expédition franklin ici catherine
françois radio-canada gatineau